- [Narrator] Here's a quick overview
of our free motivation
program, Khan Kickoff.
Let's start with a challenge,
which is that motivating
students right now
is just super hard.
With everything going on in the world,
getting students to show
up and engage day-after-day
is no easy feat,
but teachers did report one
bright spot from the fall,
which was the power of teamwork.
Specifically, hundreds
of educators told us
that having students work
together to make progress
and learn storm, got their
classes to show up and work hard
even during incredibly tough times.
So, Khan kickoff builds on that same sense
of camaraderie to get your
students energized this winter.
Here's how it works.
So, all you have to do is
go to your activity overview
and then on a weekly basis
copying your student's progress
right into your progress tracker.
And then you set up your teams,
either within your classroom
breaking into groups,
competing against other periods
or even other classrooms.
And then you celebrate your
progress with the big reveal,
the scoreboard, and a chance to celebrate.
And that celebration
includes custom certificates
with each student being acknowledged
on their own personalized certificate,
as well as the ability for you
as the teacher to take
your own little victory lap
and show off with your certificate
to your fellow educators.
And when you do that
you're gonna be automatically
entered into our giveaway,
which features 10 prize packs
that include a Wacom drawing tablet,
just like the one that Sal Khan
uses and the $100 gift card.
So, you can commission
your own celebration videos
from top athletes and performers.
And best of all Khan kickoff is free
and open to all educators.
So, feel free to dive in today.